Now that you've learned how
to make an engaging game,
let's talk about the best
ways to make money with it.
How do you build a profitable game?
>> The most obvious way is to
price a game, say, at $0.99.
Then anyone who wants to play your
game has to pay to download it.
These are called Premium games.
>> I've seen a few games
like that in the App Store.
But mostly I see free games.
How to games that are free
to download make a profit?
>> Those are called Freemium games, and
they use a combo of ads and
in-app purchases to make money.
>> And in this lesson, we'll learn
more about monetization strategies for
both Freemium and Premium games.
>> We'll see what works and
what doesn't for
each model, and even show you how to
implement your ads In an Android game.
>> After this lesson,
you'll be able to choose the best
ways to monetize your game.